managed instance groups are handy when  you need several vm's that are  configured identically to create an  instance templates start in the compute  section of the cloud console click  instance templates create instance  template name your template pick a  machine type update the boot disk if you  need to and configure the rest of the  options in the way that works for your  project this process is nearly identical  to setting up the single instance be  sure to check the allow HTTP traffic and  allow HTTP traffic boxes if you need to  there are additional options including  the ability to add an SSH key in the  collapsed section here now click create  to use this template you select it in  the list and you click create instance  group I hope you found this cloud minute  helpful